dix ans charlie se prépare comme
d'autres enfants ou retour à l'école
pendant la moitié de sa vie l'a surmonté
bien des épreuves ici mais je fais tu as
droit cause la chine est aujourd'hui est
une survivante du cancer est content de
moi j'ai cinq ans les choses
s'annonçaient pourtant mal elles avaient
des symptômes de nous guérir
donc on est à l'hôpital le 23 décembre
puis un fait
il nous a diagnostiqué un premier
exposés
nous c'est me donc le tout là toute la
vie de bascule à l'été prix vraiment
piètre état
ce thème une tare d'hémoglobine pourriez
laquelle lutté pour sa vie
c'est comme par l on essaye toujours de
pouvoir dire sur la sécurité notre
famille piquet au bois robien le tu peux
rien faire c'est carrément dojack faute
lui fasse confiance
celui-ci me représente le tiers des
cancers chez les enfants de moins de 14
ans quelqu'un on apporte un soutien
psychologique physique et financier aux
familles touchées
le danger c'est de rester isolées des
séquelles majeures sur toute la famille
sont les parents sur l'enfant atteint la
fratrie
à l'école on te concentrer sur charlie
de façon générale en tout et pour tout
80 2 % des enfants vont s'en sortir
c'est sûr que l'on parle de survie et
non de guérison complète privée
d'activité normale pendant longtemps
charlie rattrape le temps perdu elle
n'est pas de droit de la grand choc
pendant quelques années tu mets ton
enfant dans une bulle ce qui est privé
de tout ce que ses amis fofolle maladie
grave qu'il faut que tu étais vraiment
difficile mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas ce travers choisi est en rémission
depuis deux ans mais la partie n'est pas
encore gagnée d'eau subir des tests tous
les six mois
la famille se croiser doigt étant de
profiter de tous les bons moments ici
une chaîne marsolais radio-canada
verchères